Hey, it's Mike here and I'm not sure if
you heard about my community called
Strategic Traders. You know, it's a it's
a community that I've been working on
for about the the last 6 months that,
you know, traders have been joining and
been seeing some great results from. So,
you know, right now
traders inside Strategic Traders are
learning how to read not just order
flow, but the market in general like
institutional traders do and they're
seeing real results. So, let me show you
what's changing for them. Let me just uh
drag it in here really quick. This is uh
the Strategic Traders Thanskool. This is
the community and you know, right now we
got 287 members and you know, every day,
you know, people are posting things like
this, right? Uh Lukman is talking about
a quick trade that he took uh just on
the reopen. This is just 29 minutes ago
um
about 1K not too shabby and you can see
his uh results here. This is on his uh
funded account. He passed the
evaluation. That's great. You know, his
total P&L is what? 5,992.
Let's see his uh results here. You know,
it's really nice uh over the last uh
week, basically.
These are his results and he's passed
his evaluation.
Now,
the thing about Strategic Traders is,
you know, it's not only, you know,
people sharing their wins, you know, but
also showing you how they do it. So, I'm
going to share with you how three
traders in my community, Strategic
Traders, walked away with 2,000, 9,550,
8,375 from setups shared and learned
inside Strategic Traders. And the best
part is that the traders share their
exact setups inside Strategic Traders so
that you can learn them and spot the
next one. So, here's one setup. Crude
oil. This is uh delta divergence of
price exhaustion, delta divergence at
the low of the day followed by
exhaustion on the pullback, right? And
you can see his trades here. He's
getting long at uh 8889 and he's getting
out at uh 5610. So, that's uh you know,
a nice 20, just over 20 ticks on
five contracts. Um here's another setup.
Silver one and done for the day. $9,000
in 2 minutes. This is a great simple
setup. Verticality buy,
uh volume pressure spike gives a buy
signal, bid ask momentum signal buy.
Target was just uh was the prior
internal swing point. Just the one trade
for me today. Time to go out and play.
Right? This is the chart and you can
see, you know, where he's getting long,
you know, where his profit is, where his
targets are. You know, they they and the
beauty is, you know, these traders are
in strategic traders every day. They
post this. You got a question about it?
You ask them directly.
It's not just about asking me questions,
but meeting other traders who are doing
what you want to do. You know, the best
place
best way to learn something is to put
yourself
together with other people that are
doing what you want to do. This is um
setup number three, trade on the
E-minis. This is from
uh Pascal. You know, why did he goes
explains why he took the trade. Price
was at the current day low. Price came
back to demand level plus ICT order
block. You know, it's not just about
using a volume footprint chart. You
know, traders use all different forms of
analysis inside strategic traders. And
you're going to find, you know,
some things really resonate with you
more than others. You know, he talks
about using the 10-range chart, what he
saw on it, what he saw on the 1-minute
chart. Okay? And, you know, here's the
charts that he put You know, he's got
them all nice and marked up. You can
see, you know, 10 contracts, he's in the
money
$8,375
before he takes his profits.
So, the best part is these are just a
few of the trade setups being discussed
and shared inside strategic traders
every day. Not just by me, but by other
successful traders. You know, here's
another example, right? This is um using
the RV bars, okay? Reversal bars.
Talking about the abandoned value area
with a retest, right? Getting short five
contracts. He's already in the money
$3,325.
You can see where his target is. He's
not that far off from his target. Um
here's another example
with the chart up, this is uh trade
the traders $6,875
in the profit already. He hasn't even
hit his take profit, but he goes over
exactly what he is seeing in the chart.
Okay, here's another one.
He's short.
He's showing you why he's short, you
know, there's there's explanations
together with the chart. It's not just a
a chart with the number on it, but the
traders go through all the explanations.
This trade is $6,187
in the money.
So, for over 20 years I was a
professional trader at places like JP
Morgan, Commerzbank, and Cargill. But,
here's what even more important, you
know, over those last 10 years, right,
since I left the corporate banking
world, I've coached over a thousand
traders on how to trade order flow
successfully. And a few months ago,
actually about six months ago, I think
it was September, I created Strategic
Traders Community so traders can
interact and better understand order
flow analysis to build their own edge in
the market. I realized in trading that
not everyone makes it, but the ones who
follow my tried and true methods, they
see consistent results. You know, and
this is what the inside of Strategic
Traders looks like, right? It It runs on
the school platform, you know, this is
the
Where am I here?
Uh
Let me get it here. This is it right
here. Um this is it currently right now
and you can scroll through. We've got
sections called the general discussion.
We got all general discussion, wins,
trade setups, indicator,
funded accounts. We've even got
classrooms in here where I've got all my
trading courses. So, you know, if you
want access to all
my workshops, trading courses that I've
done in the past and will be doing in
the future, you're going to be able to
access them in here. Um you can see the
calendar, you know, when we do our
Strategic Traders weekly calls as well
as the order flow traders calls. You'll
have access to those as well.
The traders in my community, Strategic
Traders, aren't professionals with years
of experience. Many of them started
exactly where you are right now,
frustrated with traditional analysis
that doesn't seem to work for them. But
the ones who learned order flow, they've
gone from breaking even or losing money
to becoming consistent traders. And in
the past 3 months, many traders are now
successfully implementing these exact
strategies as well as sharing strategies
that work for them.
You know, the amount of trading
knowledge they share is unbelievable.
I'm even learning new ways to trade and
I've been trading since the '90s, right?
This is a
great trade. You know, with the
potential, you can see it right here. It
says potential to generate $12,500
profit. Not too shabby for a day's work,
I agree. You know, he's just trading
five lots, but this setup would give you
about $12,500
when it works in profit and you're
futures trading a five lot, that's what
your potentials can be. Um you know,
today he had uh 10 clear setups.
You got 10
You got 10 clear setups with the $1,250
profit. The You do the math. That's
12,500. Not saying that it's going to
happen, but this is what traders are
sharing inside of Strategic Traders.
Talks about the potential that you can
see. You know, here's a trade in the
ultra bonds, right? Easy trade ultra
bonds that you see quite regularly, low
of the day plus yesterday's low.
Notice the three times open POC and
accumulation distribution in a row
signaling bullishness. Hope you'll learn
from it. Right? This is what traders are
showing inside Strategic Traders so that
you can learn from it. You know, it's
not just uh you know, reading in a
textbook, "Oh, you know, this is what
you should be doing." It's traders
Again, the beauty is
if you got a question about this, you
can ask it to the trader himself.
Strategic Traders members are getting
funded using order flow setups they
learned here. They're not exceptional
traders, you know, but they are normal
people who have finally understood what
institutional buyers and sellers are
doing. They all have one thing in
common, they stopped guessing and
started reading the actual order flow
and price action.
You know, this trader talks about his
fourth evaluation in four days. He wants
to get on to the fifth one. Thanks you
again, Mr. Mike and and Mr. Chris.
You know, this guy passed three
evaluations in 10 days. I don't have
much money to fully fund my account, but
many thanks to Michael.
And the other trader, I've been able to
pass three evaluations test and forward
test silver on three evaluation accounts
thanks to the simple rules Mr. Mike put
forward. You know, here's slingshotting
on this one of the setups slingshotting
the Apex evaluation silver in the POC
slingshot pays out again. I took this
POC slingshot a little early and could
have waited for the retest rejection,
but the result was still the same great
volume through
this move with target being the upper
Delta divergence zone.
Okay, and and here's uh
here's the trades that he took right
here on Ninja Trader. Okay, so here's
what I see happening with most traders.
They're
using price action alone. They're
following the crowd. They're trading
based on what they think should happen
next instead of what the order flow and
price action is telling them will happen
next. And that's why they lose. The
successful traders that are reading
order flow and combining it with price
action or combining it with other forms
of analysis. They're seeing aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers. They're
watching volume at specific price
levels. They understand the auction.
That's their edge. You know, our traders
aren't just scalping e-mini futures.
There are traders
consistently profitable on NQ, you know,
the Nasdaq, MES micros, crude oil, and
even crypto futures using the same order
flow and price action principles.
Different markets, same edges. Last week
alone a trader in the community shared
results on hitting a 1K target using a
setup he learned in Strategic Traders.
And again, you know, just literally
before I sat down to record this video,
you know, that
we had the trader here. He talked about
hitting his uh
right on the reopen during Asian hours.
Quick trade before he hit the plane to
return to his home.
About 1K, not too shabby, right? And he
shows the chart. And again, you know,
if you have a question on their setup,
you could just type it in here. This is
great, you know, what are you doing?
Right? You just type it in here, you can
reply,
add your comment. Great job, you know,
it it helps traders when other traders
um, you know, tell them you're doing
great. You know, gives them gives you as
a trader motivation when you share what
you're doing, what's working for you
with other traders. Because, you know,
being part of a community is important.
And it's hard as a trader because, you
know, we're sitting in our home or or
our home office, whatever you want to
call it. You know, we're trading by
ourselves. We don't have anyone to run
ideas through. And that's one of the
reasons why I created Strategic Traders
so that we'll have
um,
traders being at that we can communicate
with, that we can talk to, get to know.
Um, you know, here's another
setup discussed, right? And you can see,
again, another 1K target hit for
Christian Shing. Um, he continues to be
your students, right?
Strategic Traders is a community where I
teach you everything that I've learned
about order flow and price action
analysis. Not just me, but other traders
also contribute. We have weekly group
coaching calls where we walk through
live charts, analyze real market data,
break down exactly what the order flow
is showing us, and discuss how to turn
that into profitable setups. You get
access to my complete course library,
you know, on footprint charts, delta
analysis, imbalance trading, bar by bar
analysis, tape reading, everything. You
also get a community support where you
can ask questions, get feedback on your
charts, and learn directly from traders
who are actively using those strategies
right now. And to be honest, you know,
the traders that I see that are doing
well now, when they joined, they didn't
just sit back and, you know, wait for
other people to post. They got active.
They sat there, you know, they've read
the post, you know, they commented,
"Okay, I I I don't understand this part
of your analysis."
Um, you know, or they they post their
analysis to get feedback
from other traders. Maybe they're
missing they feel they're missing
something on their chart and by asking
other traders, you know, it helps them
understand what they're missing and how
to become a better trader.
But you want to know the real secret
sauce? It's what the other members are
sharing with each other. You don't get
better trading by yourself in a vacuum,
right? You need interaction with other
traders to bounce ideas off, to work
together to create new winning
strategies. This is
There's a saying, right? Iron sharpens
iron and by surrounding yourself with
successful traders, your path is up. And
I'm going to share something with you
that that is very
nice that's going on in there right now.
You know, here we're working on
something.
And you see, right? This is it starts
with the traders idea
setup and then it comes all the way
down, you know, people are creating
graphics on them, you know, thanks.
Shout out to to Keith. And
it is even at the point now where, you
know, people are sort of coding them up
and sharing the code for it. Sharing
their their indicator, right? That
they've created.
You know, so that's
that's the beauty of
being in a trading community where you
can learn from others, that you can
share ideas with. Because you know what?
You know, you may be interested in, you
know, some of these ideas. You may be
interested in um
you know, a certain way of analysis,
Fibonacci or something. But you don't
know anybody else that is. You come to a
place like
like strategic traders, you can, you
know, post
you know, your thoughts on Fibonacci.
Other traders that are interested in
Fibonacci will jump in and, you know,
and from there that you guys can start
communicating, start bouncing ideas off
each other, see what one, you know, may
works for you, doesn't work for somebody
else, what works for somebody else. Um
you know, maybe you could add that into
your own trading, okay?
Now, you might be thinking, "Will will
this work for me? You know, I'm new to
trading. Is Strategic Trader really
worth it?" You know, the answer is yes,
if you're willing to learn, right? You
just You know, with trading or with
education in general, you know, once you
learn something, it's it's in your
brain, right? You've you've learned it.
And you might be wondering, "How much
does this cost?" Because, you know,
right now, you know, times are tough. I
understand that. You know, normally it
costs $147 a month to join Strategic
Traders, but for a limited limited time,
you're going to get lifetime access for
just a small one-time payment. Just one
payment and you're grandfathered in. No
hidden fees, no upsells. You get full
access to everything, trade setups,
courses, calls, and most importantly,
the community.
You know, this is what Darren wrote. He
says, "I can't quite believe how quickly
my trading has improved since joining
here. Michael Baltazar, thanks for
putting this all together and keep up
with the short videos. Really helpful
and appreciated."
You know, the market doesn't wait,
right? And neither should you. Traders
who started learning order flow 3 months
ago now understand what is happening in
the market, but they had to act first.
The window of opportunity is always now.
Now,
you can join Strategic Traders by going
to the link
www.strategictraders.com
and get involved in the weekly calls,
introduce yourself in our community,
start watching the course content today,
and you're going to start winning. Now,
again, you know, just really quick, I'll
go back to the price cuz, you know,
that's the million-dollar question. How
much are you going to pay for this? And,
you know, if you go to the website
strategictraders.com. Again, you know,
this runs on school, but if you go to
strategictraders.com,
okay?
You're going to see here down scroll
down at the bottom.
Okay, you got two ways to pay. You can
pay by Stripe or you can pay by PayPal.
And right now, I've got a very limited
time offer. It's $297 for lifetime
access. Okay?
Normally, it's $147 a month, or $997 a
year. But for now,
I'm letting more people in at just $297.
So, basically, you're paying for less
than 2 months, but you're going to get
lifetime access. All right? This is
really the best deal you're going to
find. So, to get started, just go to
strategictraders.com.
Again, it's this page that I'm on. It's
www.strategictraders.com.
Start winning, and I'm going to see you
guys on the inside.